Every person who is traveling outside of
his home country um is buying a data
plan. Sure. And then the question is
from who? It's not a question if, it's a
question about from who. Yes. And then
that's where we come into place. So you
have multiple options. You have the
telecom providers that they charge you
premium prices 100 200 300 shekels which
is equivalent to almost $100. Um and
it's expensive. It's a pretty expensive
deal. So they tell you yes, you get like
50 gigabytes, 30 days, you know, things
that are not relevant for for your
actual usage. And then you have all
those uh uh providers like us um that
basically are selling uh data plans at
affordable rates um um and that's where
the competition comes into place. We
what we did is that we partnered with
more than 500 network operators around
the world. So telecom operators we on
top of that we developed like a
technology that basically allowed us to
use one eim or SIM card doesn't matter
it's the same thing around the world. So
it's one SIM or EIM global connectivity
it doesn't matter where you where you
travel and then what happens is that you
can bounce between multiple countries
and and have one basically the same ESIM
or SIM card uh connected to wherever you
go. Um so it's similar to what you have
with the telecom companies but it's just
that you get like local service. Sure.
Um so the internet is faster, the
experience is faster. Um and the price
is onetenth of the price.
[Music]
Really really happy to have you here.
Thank you for coming all the way here to
Tel Aviv. Thank you. Thank you for
inviting me. Although it was a long trip
from the kibuts, but I made it. I
appreciate it. Well, I'm really excited
to hear about your story and to hear
about Voy and your insights, your
experiences, this new world that you're
in. Well, tell me a little bit about how
you got even into the world of, you
know, of business development and
entrepreneurship. You you the the
journey that you're on, it's not
trivial. you've gotten a chance to be a
part of a bunch of different awesome
organizations in different continents.
Today you're the CEO of of Voy. Um you
also got a chance to lead operations at
a very substantial company Tango, right?
Yeah. So so I would love to hear about
these different aspects and then we'll
talk about Voy. Sure.
So um after being in the US for 10 years
working uh doing my undergrad and
masters in the US working at City Bank
and then in a private equity uh we moved
back to Israel after 10 years in New
York back to the kibuts which is kind of
180 degrees opposite. Um but that's what
my wife wanted so we did it. Uh I'm very
uh you know I listen to what she says
and and that's what I did. Um I joined
here back in 2016. I joined Tango uh not
Tango Payonir. That was the beginning of
a small fintech company. A small today
it's small. Well even back in the day it
was around 500 employees but uh I'm
joking of course. Yeah. Yeah. So and and
one of the verticals that uh I was
focusing on was uh the live streaming.
Um and that's how I met Tango. Um and
part of the the the relationship is that
I always told him like uh why don't you
do this and why don't you do that? So he
told me stop telling me what to do join
us and do. So I joined them when they
were like 15 employees as a COO and we
took the company to be around 400
employees, seven different locations,
more than $300 million revenue and
that's uh within uh a little bit more
than two years. Um then I left uh I went
to a startup which unfortunately failed.
Um uh it's also important to fall during
your journey. Um so I was the CEO of a
startup and we had some uh capital
issues. That's was uh that it was 2022
where the the
the all
the rates went high and it was the the
the money was expensive. So it was very
difficult to raise capital. Um
unfortunately the startup uh didn't uh
go to the the direction that I wanted to
and and that's where we we we divorced
and I joined uh Voy that was like uh a
little bit more than a year ago. Um
basically Voy it's a very interesting
story. Um but I kind of took the company
uh kind of a skeleton company no product
no like yes there was a vision but no
real product. Um we we had capital, we
had a vision um and we started uh doing
some uh cooperations with different uh
OTAAS and airlines. So we work today
with a if you go to aod.com that's the
booking brand in uh in Asia. So you see
that they sell EIMS and this is
basically our product. But we are
basically a connectivity company. We
provide connectivity to a lot of
different line of businesses. It can be
for for the auto industry. It can be for
terminals. It can be for anyone
basically that needs connectivity. The
focus of Voy currently is is on the uh
the B2C side of it is mostly focused on
the travel industry. Um but we are going
to introduce additional uh services soon
which is going to be like local
connectivity local uh telecom services
around the world. Um so we are in the
process of being like cert like virtual
operators in certain countries. Um so
we're kind of uh becoming another
telecom operator which in in in the in
the professional world it's called uh
MVNO. It's a virtual network operator.
It's a mobile virtual network operator
and we and we're going to ride on the
existing uh networks. Um but we have
very interesting uh ideas for for the
future. So so you know I think that a
lot of time well today certainly I think
most of us take connectivity for granted
the fact that we're connected and and
yeah we see the the 3G 4G 5G uh signs on
our phones and and we almost assume
natively that wherever we are we're
going to have some level of coverage. Uh
but but I think this is not a trivial
space. Um, and I'm I I'd like you to
give me a little bit of a background as
to what is this all what is the space
all about? What have what have been the
big I guess milestones in the evolution
of the space of connectivity and where
we are today. So, so I I would I
wouldn't go deep into the evolution and
everything. I'll go a little bit to to
what are we challenging and what are we
tackling today. So, I think the main
focus today is uh especially when when
traveling abroad. So connectivity became
essentiality. Everybody needs to be
connected to everywhere you go. Um when
you're in your home country, it's
something that is very simple because
you have your your subscription and it's
something that you it's with you all the
time. Um but when you're traveling
abroad, this is where the complexity uh
again it's not that complex today, but
the complexity comes in. So telecom
providers well just to understand the
complexities I have a SIM right in my
phone that SIM is associated with
certain providers and carriers in my
home country. Yeah. And when I travel
abroad simply we're not talking it's not
the same carriers it's not the same
providers. Right. So that's where the
roaming comes into place. right
now today let's let's go to the basic
today everybody who travels um they need
uh a data plan they need connectivity
when they travel the moment you land the
first thing you do is you turn on your
your your you get out of airplane mode
and you check your emails you step out
of the airport you're ordering your Uber
um you're walking in the city you need
Google Maps you cannot stay disconnected
and this was not the case in the past
this is a new expectation which now has
become almost trivial but it's it's a
standard. It's a standard and and
because of that everybody like every
person who is traveling outside of his
home country um is buying a data plan.
Sure. And then the question is from who?
It's not a question if it's a question
about from who. Yes. And then that's
where we come into place. So you have
multiple options. you have the telecom
providers that they charge you premium
prices 100 200 300 shekels which is
equivalent to almost $100 um and it's
expensive it's a pretty expensive deal
so they tell you yes you get like 50
gigabytes 30 days you know things that
are not relevant for for your actual
usage and then you have all those uh uh
providers like us um that basically are
selling uh data plans at affordable
rates Um um and that's where the
competition comes into place. We what we
did is that we partnered with more than
500 network operators around the world.
So telecom operators we on top of that
we developed like a technology that
basically allowed us to use one eim or
SIM card doesn't matter it's the same
thing around the world. So it's one SIM
or EIM global connectivity. It doesn't
matter where you where you travel. And
then what happens is that you can bounce
between multiple countries and and have
one basically the same eim or sim card
uh connected to wherever you go. Um so
it's similar to what you have with the
telecom companies but it's just that you
get like local service. Sure. Um so the
internet is faster, the experience is
faster. Um and the price is onetenth of
the price. Um and with that price range
again you're saying okay so there are
many competitors but when you have a
hundred billion dollar market yearly
like a addressable market of hundred
billion dollars yearly um there's enough
room for a lot of competition that's one
um and two a lot of uh players can make
a lot of money here so we're fighting in
a very uh ordinary market um pricing
here is very competitive but also the
service um and one of of the things that
we focus on is the customer experience.
Right. So tell me a little bit about the
customer experience and what what's
what's happening there. So one of one of
one of the most important things that we
figured out is
that installing like a new SIM card or
eim it's uh it's not straightforward.
Why? The the manufacturers they they do
it not simple on purpose. Why? Because
if you go to your phone and you want to
install a new SIM or ESIM device, uh
basically what happens is a billing
action. So suddenly you start being
charged by a different carrier. So they
want to make sure that you you
understand what you do and they ask you
like multiple times. Um so when you
arrive to to your destination and you
start doing that, what happens is that
you're a little bit stressed. It works.
It doesn't work. You need to contact
support. don't have internet because we
created that layer of technology of of
those 500 networks and and the one EIM.
So, what we do is that you buy your your
your plan while you're in Israel. You
get like a local small uh data plan. You
install it while you're home at home.
You check that it works. If it works
here, it's going to work all over the
world. Why is it important that that you
install it here? It it's not important.
It's just it's a stressfree, you know,
like when you're environment. you're not
you're not in the airplane waiting. So
you just you're you're just releasing
the stress from arriving and and the
unknown of being connected, not being
connected. So you know that you like
again when when people are frequent
travelers, they want to know that things
are kind of uh the boxes are checked.
Yes. So it's checking the box knowing
that okay I'm going to be connected and
I know that that this is another thing
that I sorted. Same as entrance, same as
I don't know. Absolutely. So, so this is
the unique feature which it it sounds
like very trivial and very simple but
it's not simple. It's actually not at
all. When I travel I I've used the arrow
until now and I and maybe and I'll use a
voy. So yeah, um you should uh uh you
should try Voy. Um but but this is a
unique feature that No, cuz I'm thinking
to myself, you know, I frequently, you
know, I make I make the point of
purchase when I land and then I have
this moment this this oh shoot moment of
oh okay, maybe what if this doesn't
work? Uh, and in fact, the way that I've
compromised it is I've I've taken on
paying a lot of money to another vendor,
Google, to get global coverage just in
the case my airl doesn't work because I
can't have the idea that I won't be
connected when I travel. So, you're just
one out of billions who is traveling and
is afraid to stay disconnected. Um and
that's
uh yes but it just gives you an
understanding of how big is this market
and how um how unique and how like how
we are trying to make it so simple for
you to stay connected wherever you go
because connectivity became
essentiality. So all the time build like
creating like different solutions for
for the travelers and also um I don't
know if this is a challenge for you or
not but a lot of like we we we are now
launching like multiple phone like you
can have like local phone numbers in
multiple countries. So you go to Japan,
you have like a local phone number in
the US, you go to UK like you can have
multiple local phone numbers and then
you can use them locally or like
communicate locally. So it gives you
also the solution of of uh the voice
because usually like people even though
people today are mostly using data some
people still need the voice and here
we're solving that as well. Yeah. So
we're doing multiple things um including
becoming uh local telecom providers in
multiple countries around the world. Ah
interesting. So to give like a a much
better like in our name is Voy Global.
So we're going to have Voy Local as
well. Interesting. So Voy Local is going
to be Voy Local in multiple countries.
So where do you see the space heading?
So what's are are we as consumers are we
should we expect any
significant changes to our experience in
the coming years in terms of
connectivity? So I think that more we
we're already in a very problematic
situation in our life that if you don't
have connectivity you don't know how to
navigate to anywhere. You don't know
your passwords. you don't know how to
you're you're kind of uh you're lost
without connectivity. So I think that
the connectivity issue is already rooted
in us. Um and it's just going to get
worse. Um now that becoming worst is the
opportunity as well. Um I think that um
more the the dependency and connectivity
is going to be much higher. Um it's
going to be for we already see that even
like uh today like so in the past you
were waiting for public transportation
in the station and and okay it comes
when it comes today like everything is
on time like you need to be on time you
need to know where the schedule so h how
is that schedule happening like think
about all the connect like everything is
connected all the cars are going to be
connected like they're already connected
but they're going to be connected in a
much more
uh complicated and uh uh envi like
everything is going to everything must
communicate with each other and how are
you going to do that so that's exactly
the connectivity when you're talking
about smart uh like uh autonomous
vehicles when you're talking about like
uh all the IoT and everything every like
it's all about connectivity how do you
connect all those things together that
you don't have accidents you don't have
uh uh the the the car always arrives on
time the the airplanes There are no
delays. There are no like it's all about
how do you gather all the data and you
organize it and and how do you transfer
the data. So connectivity is going to be
a bigger part of our life. It's already
a huge thing in our life but it's going
to be even bigger. Um and I think that
that's why it's a very interesting
market for for us. Um and that's why I
see that as a challenge and also as an
opportunity and that's why it's fun.
Yeah. So if you had to think you know in
your own thesis and and your
prioritization what are the big
differentiators in in the space. So you
you mentioned that it's a very
competitive space pricing a is a big
factor customer experience or the the
user journey is a big factor but you
know what what really is at the root the
winners and so infrastructure it's very
complicated to to build your own
infrastructure here. Mhm. Um it's
something that takes years. Um most of
those uh
uh telecom providers they're writing on
other like uh core like the core
infrastructure they're they're licensing
it from someone else. There are very few
uh companies that own the
infrastructure. Um and uh I think that
this is really the challenge the it's
it's basically the economy of scale. How
do you take, you know, the the the
economy of scale and build
infrastructure and then be able to to
slice and dice it between and and resell
it in multiple ways. So that's the
challenge. Um the entry barrier is not
high. Um providing uh competitive
pricing is challenging. um building the
infrastructure and the ability and the
technology to to do the counting and all
the billing on your end
is it's it's it requires some
investments and budgets and and it's not
that simple. Um so at the end of the day
we see a lot of different again
everywhere you see telecom providers.
Well, what's the difference between A
and B? Um all of them are giving pretty
much the same. I think that the
difference is the user experience, how
simple it is, and that's really the the
the challenge to to do all the the the
to connect all the dots, build the
infrastructure like in a scalability
way. Um, and then basically taking over
the markets, partnerships, a lot of
these type of things. These are
basically the the the challenges that we
are facing in
our industry today. So, so what's really
exciting for you as a CEO? Depends
when. Depends when. But again, it's it's
I enjoy being the the CEO not because
I'm the CEO. I enjoy because we
basically started two people the
company. Um and we are building
it very in a very lean and mean way.
That's one. and two we are building it
in a
very we focus on the DNA of the people
that we hire which is uh it's the first
time I'm doing it in that way um I've
been already in multiple uh leadership
roles let's call it like that um but
it's the first time that I'm really
enjoying
uh you know the product I'm enjoying the
the people I'm enjoying the the the
environment I'm enjoying like again the
growth we are already in a very nice run
rate, you know. So, all everything goes
very well. It's just that we need to
continue. And again, there is a huge vi
like a very brightful vision for what we
do and and we're we're in the process of
uh uh expanding and acquiring companies
and in order to grow faster. So,
interesting stuff. You know, it's a fun
place to be in. Um and I hope you'll be
there as well. Awesome. Si, thank you so
much for joining me. Really appreciate
your time and thank you for inviting me.
Thank you so much.